and do you guys feel this is a question
for three cuz I as a musician I what do
you get from it do you feel like there's
a there's purpose in playing music or is
it just a passion or something you just
love like what is it exactly Rob start I
want I want to hear right I mean I play
a lot of piano so it's hard to play
drums by yourself for more than like 30
minutes and it gets a little weird you
know you just you just want the other
guys with in the room you know so I'll
move to the piano that I can do forever
and and it's like healing you know just
a it's just healing the tones and just
it makes you feel good I mean music
listening to it playing it yeah it's the
same that people that don't play and
they listen it's the same thing being a
in a musician it's a little bit
different but I think it's the same tone
you know just that it just makes you
feel F filled up you know
Brad use my mic yeah Feel Jesus he's my
Bas
yeah I think it's just that one of those
few things in the world that allows you
to shut the world out you know it's for
me at least it's you know when you're
playing a three minute song or whatever
it is or sometimes just listening to
music but when you're playing I don't
know if it's because you're using all
your brain focusing on the guitar and
the singing or whatever it is but the
world as you know it just goes away
you're not thinking about anything else
you know even if sometimes if you're
sick or whatever you can still play and
have that couple minutes where nothing
exists except the feeling like Rob said
of that you know I agree so it's really
it's really fun and then the song's over
and then you're like let's start another
one quick do you ever play play while
you're playing like you're playing a
song just say you're by yourself and
then all of a sudden you're listening to
what yourself doing but you don't want
to be taken away from it to distract you
but yet the act of just listening to
what you're doing can sort of make you
go into a different mode or something
like oh you know it's not like oh I'm
I'm you know just just the T the tones
of the guitar does that ever distract
you I have a problem where I'm playing
and all of a sudden I'm like oh this is
good and then I [__] it up completely
you become a fan of yourself stop
thinking it's good just just keep being
yeah how do you do that I don't know
like do you ever happen in acting when
you know you have like a they call it
like a happening when something oh yeah
very rare it's no it is you know what
I'm talking about when you actually feel
like it's not planned it's just oh my
God
but if that happened all the time I'd be
Hopkins right you know so it's something
that I I wish happened all the time but
when it does happen it's like oh man
this is cool and you know it's sort of
ephemeral you know it's it's just like
it is what it is those are the moments I
those moments it happens in music too
and and I know I think in acting maybe
it's like you know improvisation or
something but I'm not talk about jazz or
anything but it does to me it happens in
music for Me Maybe it's easier because
I'm listening and sitting and like
sometimes I'll get carried away
listening listening to like something
like glimmer like Brett sings that even
Dylan Street cuz the lyrics and it gets
me a little sad I listen to that I sort
of get taken away I'm like you said like
K said like oh [__] or Brett said that
don't don't go off the train right
especially when you're playing front of
people like you can do that if you get
into you don't almost want to be more
robotic how do you stay that fine line
like I got to be Pro but then I but I
want to have it happening but then I
don't want to go off the train and like
go off into some I think it just K what
do you think about what about like why
do music why do you play music honestly
like what is it um it's
fun does it take you away from like
everything else um certainly yeah I'm uh
so much about music yeah love being
transported listening to
music um and I love writing songs I love
the creative aspect of it um the sense
of play I love um when you connect when
the three of us connect finding
something oh we like that building it it
um in the Journey of it becoming a song
and I I love that moment uh love the
fraternity of the band that um I love
playing live that's that's good clean
fun um but yeah I mean music is Mana
from heaven right it sustains us it
helps us share with each other it helps
us
commune yeah I always think about that I
always think like music to me is I I I
don't know what I would do without it
there's a lot of things you could do
without obviously you have to eat but
like music there's always something in
my head there's always something I'm
humming I'm singing I I crave for you
know and it's just like and if it's not
there it's it's it feels like it's
missing did you guys find that like
that's maybe that's what brought you
back you know it was sort of that
missing each other missing the music
missing all these things these elements
that deep down you knew you really loved
yeah and for me personally yes missed it
but also can only get that playing with
Robert and Brett like that was the one
thing just unique like yeah the
chemistry ass yeah the chemistry
chemistry of this band is a is very
strong